Toll! Endlich geht die Reise los!
Ja, ich bin schon sehr auf Berlin gespannt.
Warst du schon mal in Berlin?
Nein, du?
Ja, aber das war vor 15 Jahren.
Es ist schon so lange her.
Ich will unbedingt zum Brandenburger Tor gehen.
Ich auch.
Ich möchte gerne ein Fussballspiel
im Berliner Olympiastadion sehen.
Morgen spielt die Hertha BSC
Berlin gegen Borussia Dortmund.
Da bin ich dabei!
Ich habe jetzt aber Hunger.
Kriegen wir etwas zu essen?
Ja, ich glaube schon.
Bald kommt sicher etwas zu essen.
Guten Tag.
Hätten Sie gerne
etwas zu Essen und Trinken?
Ja, gerne.
Haben Sie ein Schinkensandwich?
Dazu hätte ich gerne noch eine Coca Cola.
Ich habe leider kein Schinkensandwich.
Es bleiben noch Käse- und Salamisandwiches.
Was hätten Sie gern?
Dann nehme ich gerne das Salamisandwich.
Sehr gut. Vielen Dank.
Hier, bitteschön.
Ich hätte gerne ein Käsesandwich.
Wir sind schon am Landen.
Bist du auch so aufgeregt wie ich?
Ja! Zuerst müssen wir unser Gepäck abholen.
Danach müssen wir die U-Bahn suchen.
Mit der U-Bahn werden wir zum Hotel gehen.
Sehr gut. Das wir gar kein Problem für uns.
Wir sind schon bald bei der Gepäckausgabe.
Danach müssen wir keine Passkontrolle machen.
Die Schweiz und Deutschland sind im Schengen-Raum.
Deshalb gibt es keine Passkontrollen.
Genau, das ist richtig.
Das ist viel einfacher so.
So müssen wir nicht lange warten.
Hoffentlich kommt unser Gepäck bald.
Ich möchte ins Zentrum gehen.
Ich möchte heute unbedingt eine Currywurst essen.
Ach, das hört sich ja so lecker an.
Ich bin dabei!
Und danach möchte ich
noch einen Berliner Krapfen essen.
Schau mal, unser Gepäck kommt!
Sehr gut.
Jetzt können wir noch unser Geld wechseln.
Danach gehen wir zum Bahnhof.
Guten Tag.
Ich würde gerne 300
Schweizer Franken in Euro wechseln.
Guten Tag. Sehr gerne.
Das ist kein Problem.
Für 300 Schweizer Franken erhalten Sie 260 Euro.
Ist das in Ordnung?
Dieser Wechselkurs ist aber tief.
Dann wechseln wir nur 50 Schweizer Franken.
Den Rest können wir in der Stadt wechseln.
Der Wechselkurs ist dort besser.
Ja, ich bin einverstanden.
Ok, das ist kein Problem.
Für 50 Schweizer Franken kriegen Sie 43 Euro.
Vielen Dank.
Hier können wir 2 Tickets kaufen.
Für 8 Euro kommen wir beide in die Stadt.
Das ist sehr gut.
So kommen wir schnell und günstig zum Hotel.
Wir müssen den nächsten Zug nehmen.
So kommen wir direkt zu unserem Hotel.
Das ist toll.
So kommen wir schnell zum Hotel.
Bis zu unserem Hotel haben wir 14 Stationen.
Von dort aus sind es noch 5 Minuten zu Fuss.
Das ist super.
So wird es nicht anstrengend.
Wir haben aber auch nicht viel Gepäck.
Genau. Ich hoffe nur, dass es nicht regnet.
Ja, das wäre nicht ideal.
Wir müssen beim nächsten Halt aussteigen.
Bist du bereit?
Ja, danke.